sure cool so welcome everyone to the
last day of the workshop uh so we have
an exciting schedule for this morning
we'll start with danielle kane uh from
ucsd
who is going to tell us about some joint
work with ilias diaco nicolas
take it away then okay hey yeah so uh
i'm going to talk to you today about
small covers for near zero sets of
polynomials and learning latent variable
models this is all joint work with
ilious diaconakolas from uw madison
um so let's start with the basic problem
let's look at learning gaussian mixture
models so
x here is a mixture of k let's say
spherical gaussians and rm
so uh you've got some number of means mu
i and some weights wi
and you pick one of these means with
probability proportional to its weight
and then you return a sample from the
identity covariance gaussian with that
mean
and so the problem we're going to look
at is given
sample access to such a mixture x uh
we'd like to learn the distribution x
um and so uh gaussian mixture models are
one of the oldest and best studied
latent variable models in
all statistics and it might be slightly
more natural to look at mixtures of
arbitrary gaussians rather than just
spherical ones that we are considering
here um but uh
for the case of arbitrary gaussians
there are m to the k
lower bounds at least in the statistical
query model
which suggests that it's hard to find
good algorithms there and so
hopefully in this model we'll be able to
find algorithms that are somewhat better
than that
so there are a couple of different
things that we might
mean when we talk about learning this
model
and the strongest of them is parameter
estimation what we'd like to do is we'd
like to estimate
each mean mu and each weight wi to some
error epsilon and then we'll know the
parameters of the model to
good accuracy and we can do everything
else
and there has been some work in this
area that says
well okay so if you have this mixture if
you assume that all of the weights are
at least
alpha and you assume that the means are
pairwise separated by
something like square root log one over
alpha
then there are algorithms that run in
time quasi-polynomial and
m over alpha now the lower bound on the
weight
is i mean it's essentially necessary so
that you can
guarantee that you'll actually see
samples from that component
but the separation is a little bit less
natural
unfortunately something along this line
looks like it might be necessary there's
a paper by
uh regular dragon which proves that
parameter estimation
in polynomial time is actually
information theoretically impossible
unless you assume some kind of similar
looking
separation assumption between the means
wait what does it mean information
theoretically
impossible in polynomial time uh in
polynomial numbers of samples
ah ah okay that's what you mean okay
um yeah so we're in polynomial number of
samples it's information theoretically
impossible
and so uh parameter estimation is doable
in quasi-polynomial time but only if you
make
some kind of separation assumption along
these lines
so the other thing that we might try to
do that works more generally is density
estimation
here the goal is just to learn some
distribution x hat
such that the total variation distance
between x and x hat
is at most epsilon and as is often the
case this is at least
possible information theoretically uh
it's now known that
approximately mk over epsilon squared
samples are both necessary and
sufficient
in this model to learn things uh
information theoretically
however algorithmically all the best
algorithms for this problem have run
time that's still exponential in
k and so the big question that we're
going to be trying to ask is is it
possible to close this gap there's an
exponential gap between the upper bounds
and the lower bounds here
uh what can we do to improve this
and the general strategy that we're
going to work on here is the method of
moments
so we're going to try and compute the
low degree moments of this mixture x
and then we're going to use them to
learn the full distribution
and so before we get into this too much
we should ask ourselves what
are the low degree moments of this
mixture model x
well if you just want the expectation of
x
well it's a mixture of components so the
by linearity of expectation what we
should get is we should get the
uh mixture of the expectations so we
just get the sum of wi times muy
for the second moments we look at the
expectation of the second tensor power
of x
and here we need to know the second
tensor power of this
gaussian with mean v y and then we get
the second tensor power of mu i plus the
identity
and when you sum this up you'll note
that the identity terms sort of come
out of the sum and you get the sum of w
i mu i tends to two plus the identity
and conveniently this identity term sort
of acts as this
as just an extra factor that you can
take out and
this sum of w i mui tensors the two is
really the
useful information to get out of this
and more generally it's not hard to show
that
learning the first d moments of x is
essentially equivalent to learning what
i'll call the parameter moments of x
which is the sum i going from 1 to k of
w i
times mu i tends to the t these are
basically
the moments of the distribution that's
just the distribution over the centers
of these gaussians
and not the more general gaussians
themselves
and so this is what you can learn with
moments that the question then is
given these values or approximations to
them what can we
expect to do with learning the actual
distribution
uh so how do we make use of these and
here's where we run into our
first big obstacle and the problem is
that moments alone
are not enough it is not very difficult
to construct two
mixtures of k gaussians say x and x
prime
even in one dimension so that the first
k
minus one moments x agree with the
corresponding moments of x prime
and additionally the total variation
distance of x and x prime is large in
fact
you can construct this so that none of
the means of one distribution are close
to any of the means of the other
distribution
so there's just some explicit families
that you can pick
and if you only compute k minus one
moments
it's not possible to tell which of these
two families you have
and when you say large you mean how does
it scale with k
i mean you can you can actually make
them arbitrarily far apart if you take
whatever means you have and you multiply
them by any constant
they're still going to matter yeah
i get it okay oh yeah so
there's an unbounded distance that you
can have in practice if you make the
means
too far apart there are some simple
things you can do to cluster them
um but there are you can make them close
enough they're not easily clusterable
that
that they're still going to be far apart
however in one dimension this isn't so
much of a problem in one dimension you
can always solve the problem
exhaustively you can sort of
say well gaussians in one dimension are
close to
piecewise constant functions if you make
the
pieces small enough and you can just
discretize the real line
and just learn the distribution over
this
sort of discrete intervals and it's
actually not that hard
however things become a bit more
complicated when you take this one
dimensional example
and embed it into a higher number of
dimensions you take
literally any line that you like in this
higher dimensional space and you
place means along this line in the same
way you would have for this one
dimensional example and once again you
can find a moment matching distribution
now in a higher number of dimensions and
so the problem is if you want to
distinguish between these two mixtures
you need k
moments and to compute k moments it even
to write them down
it's going to take m to the k time
however this case that i wrote down is
still
easy so let's think about this second
parameter moment matrix which we know
how to compute or
approximately at least this is m which
is the sum
of w i times mu i mu i
transpose and you'll note that the
image of m is the same as the span of
the mu
eyes now the construction that we looked
at
all of these mu eyes lie on a line and
so their span is one dimensional or
maybe two dimensional
and by computing the second parameter
moment matrix we can find
that one or two dimensional subspace we
can project everything onto it and once
again
once you're in finitely many dimensions
there are basically exhaustive
techniques that you can do
that now work in polynomial time and so
uh and so for this problem at least it's
actually not hard to do that
this technique is actually reasonably
well known i mean
generally you can reduce uh your
m-dimensional problem into a
k-dimensional problem
using techniques along this line and
this is a fairly commonly used
pre-processing step
for problems like this however
um we now just need to find a slightly
harder
counter example where uh where this
doesn't work
because uh the example that we had
the algorithm that we were just think
talking about using is fairly brittle
it only works when all of the points lie
in a low dimensional subspace
so to fix that we'll start with this low
dimensional construction that matches
moments
and we're just going to add some extra
components these purple components you
know are in both the red distribution
and the blue distribution and if we just
add a bunch of random components it's no
longer the case
that all of our component means lie in a
low dimensional subspace
so we can now find mixtures of say 2k
gaussians so that these two different
families
x and x prime they match k moments with
each other
and furthermore the means from each of
these families spans a k
dimensional subspace so dimension
reduction will only get you down to k
dimensions and then in order to
distinguish these two guys you need to
take
k-moments so
what can we hope to accomplish then with
method of moments
we can't hope to identify the all of the
individual components of x and x prime
with just a few moments but maybe what
we could hope to identify
is maybe we could identify these sort of
noisy components that we added in to
increase the dimension and then once
we've identified those we again
can't identify the individual components
of x or x
prime because they do match moments with
each other
but maybe we can identify this line that
all of the other components lie
on so the hope is we can identify the
sort of straggler random guys
and then the line where sort of this
interesting moment matching construction
is taking place
and hopefully we can do something sort
of exhaustive on that line
and have identified everything else
okay so this is sort of our goal but the
question is how
how might we be able to do this and
in order to get an idea for this let's
take another look at how this dimension
reduction step
works so we have the second parameter
moment matrix
m and you'll note that if for some
vector v
you look at v transpose m v this is the
sum
of w i times v dot mu i squared
and you get this interesting thing that
v transpose mv here is going to be zero
if and only if v dot mu i is zero
for every i and what this will allow us
to do
is if you look at the subspace of these
for which this holds
then this will give us a big subspace of
v that are orthogonal to
all of the muse and in particular
like this is exactly the subspace of b's
that are orthogonal to all the muse
it'll be a
k co dimension k subspace because we're
only imposing
k linear conditions on it and then if
you look at the subspace orthogonal to
that
you'll get a k dimensional subspace
which contains all of the means
and so sort of once again we have this
dimension reduction idea
but this sort of formulation is maybe a
little easier to generalize
so let's think about what happens if we
have higher moments
suppose that we know all the parameter
moments of degree
up to 2d well one way of interpreting
this is it means that for any polynomial
q of degree at most 2d we can compute
the sum of wi
times q of mu i and
in particular we'll run the same trick
that we did before we're going to let
p be the square of a degree d polynomial
so we have a quadratic form which takes
in the degree d polynomial p
and outputs the sum of w i times p
squared of mu
i what you'll note is that q
of p is zero if and only if p of mu i
is zero for every one of the means i and
if we can get this quadratic form we can
compute the zero subspace
uh we note that each of these p of mu i
being zero is a
single linear condition so we have a
co-dimension k subspace within the space
of
all degree d polynomials such that
these polynomials vanish on every single
one of our means
and okay so we have this big vector
space v it's co-dimension k within the
space of all degree d polynomials
such that p of mu i is 0 for every p and
v
and for every i going from 1 to k
so what does this tell us about where
the means lie well
this set of polynomials defines a
variety defines the the set of joint
zeros of these polynomials
and all of our means lie in this variety
now for sake of intuition let's bring
out some very basic algebraic geometry
the dimension of the space of degree d
polynomials on this variety
is just going to be the co-dimension of
of v within the space of all degree d
polynomials and that's at most k
on the other hand this is at least d
plus the dimension of the variety
choose d and a little bit of algebra
says that the dimension of this variety
v is therefore at most
d times k to the one over d
and the hope is that somehow we've
reduced our problem to working on this
variety v
of small dimension and so hopefully
once we've made this reduction
exhaustive algorithms should take time
now
that is only exponential in d times k to
the one and d
and i should note that you know the the
d
equals one case of this is exactly
the dimension reduction to idea that we
had before
we've got a co-dimension k subspace
within the space of linear polynomials
that
vanishes on all of our points and so
this defines a
k dimensional variety but since it's
defined by linear polynomials that means
it's just a subspace
so we found a k dimensional subspace on
which all of our points lie
and then we have exhaustive algorithms
that run in time
exponential and k okay so
yeah when d is one we've just reproduced
the dimension reduction
but unfortunately doing things for
higher degree polynomials is not
as straightforward there are a bunch of
obstacles so
the first one is just everything i did
on the last slide assumed that we knew
all of the moments exactly and of course
the best we could hope to do is
approximate these higher moments
and that's still enough to approximate
this quadratic form
q and find an approximation to the
subspace v
but if you then try and compute a
variety just from
approximations to the correct
polynomials
you're going to get garbage they're
going to have no
joint roots and it's not going to work
so we need to find a way to make this
algebra work with
approximate polynomials secondly
even if we had things that were exact
computing this variety would
might be difficult with linear
polynomials if you have a system of
linear polynomials it's
easy to figure out what the subspace
they define is
for higher degree polynomials right
computing and writing down the variety
they define
is is not necessarily easy and
even if we could write it down working
on this variety might be difficult
for a subspace we could just project
all of our points onto that subspace and
it's not hard to see that that
just reduces the problem to a lower
dimensional version
of the problem with a more complicated
variety it's not clear what kind of
projection onto the variety
you're supposed to be looking at it's
not clear what exactly that means for
the problem maybe it distorts things
somewhat
it's much harder to work with and
finally we run into this issue that
maybe even if the dimension of this
variety is small
it might still be very complicated maybe
it's a one-dimensional variety but it's
some kind of almost
space filling curve and just
knowing that all of our means lie on
this curve that basically goes
everywhere is maybe not very useful to
us
and so these are the problems that we
need to solve with our technique
and the basic idea of how we're going to
solve it is instead of
working with this variety directly we're
just going to approximate it by a comp
and approximate with a discrete set of
points that we can work with
and so the the tool that's this all
makes this all happen is the following
technical lemma which says that okay so
v is a subspace of code dimension at
most k within the set of all degree d
polynomials in rn we've got some
parameters
epsilon r and delta that have some
relation to each other
and we look at this set x it's the set
of
all x and r m that have uh l2 norm at
most
are so we need to restrict this to a
ball
such that for all polynomials in this
set v
the absolute value of p of x is at most
delta
times the norm of p so basically
we won't have all the p's vanish exactly
on these points but they're going to
nearly vanish on these points
and given this we claim that there
exists a cover of
s by balls of radius epsilon and the
size of this cover the number of balls
in this cover
is at most m which is two r over epsilon
d
k m to the o of d squared times k to the
one over d and
furthermore we can actually compute such
a cover in time polynomial
so basically what we're going to do is
we're going to approximate
this variety that we have by this union
of balls
and a few comments about this firstly
d times k to the one in d a question the
you don't care about the you didn't
specify the norm that you're choosing
have not specified the norm that i've
chosen for the polynomials
it doesn't really matter very much since
different natural norms will only change
by something like an
m to the d factor which uh
somehow has already been sorted into how
small delta needs to be
right yeah um but yeah i mean just using
like the l2 norm of coefficients or
something is
good enough okay um
okay so but why do we expect something
like this to be true
well if this was exact the dimension of
this variety would be
at most d times k to the one and d and
so
you expect that if you're covering a
manifold of that dimension
with balls of radius epsilon you should
have a cover of size approximately
r over epsilon the o of d times k to the
one in d
and so our bound is a little bit worse
than this we have an
extra factor of d in the exponent we
have some extra polynomial factors in
the base
but morally speaking um
this amounts to more or less the same uh
we have a requirement on delta that
delta is
less than something like epsilon over r
to the o of d
and something along these lines seems to
be necessary to ensure that the width of
the set s
is at most epsilon because even if s
approximates a low dimensional variety
if its width is more than epsilon it's
going to be hard to approx to cover by
epsilon balls
um and finally we don't have time to go
into the proof here in much depth
what i'll say is that the proof is
essentially elementary it doesn't
use anything complicated from algebraic
geometry or anything
it just uses some clever recursions a
bunch of linear algebra principle
component analysis
things like that uh but it is quite
involved it's not
a simple proof but it isn't elementary
but okay so given this how are we going
to use it so
we want to learn this mixture of
spherical gaussians
so firstly we reduce this problem to k
dimensions using the
basic dimension reduction that we've
already talked about
the next step that you need to perform
is you need to cluster the points there
are some
relatively easy things that you can do
to sort of reduce
the case where all of your means have
absolute value say polynomial and
k next we're going to let delta be
say epsilon over k to some large
multiple of d
we're going to compute the first two d
moments x to error something like delta
over four
delta to the four divided by k to the o
of d
and from that we can compute the first
2d parameter moments
to error say delta to the fourth
from this we define our quadratic form q
of p is approximately the sum
of w i p of mu i squared
and we're going to let v be the span of
all the small eigenvalues of q
and what's not hard to see is that if
you have any mu
where the wi is reasonably large
it's going to be approximately zero for
every p
in this subspace and so we're going to
define
s as before and we know that uh
uh for for each i where wi is reasonably
big the corresponding mu
will be in this s and applying the
proposition we compute a cover c
for this set and now we know we've got
this explicit
set of points such that for every i
where the weight is at least
say epsilon over k mu i is within
epsilon of some elements of this set
now how do we deal with this well if we
want to do density estimation
we note that if we take each of these
muse and round them to the nearest
element of our cover
well all the reasonably heavy news they
were only moved by
epsilon and so we've only changed the
distribution by epsilon
so in particular our original
distribution x is
o of epsilon close to some mixture
of nci distributions where c was in
our cover and so what we have is we have
an explicit set of distributions
and we have sample access to some x
which is close to being a mixture
of these explicit distributions
and it turns out that that problem is
actually reasonably
easy to solve basically you can compute
a maximum likelihood estimator for x
as being written as such a mixture
and the analysis is not very difficult
to show that this actually converges
and so the theorem is if you have a
mixture of k
spherical gaussians and m dimensions you
can learn it into error epsilon
well you need poly m over epsilon time
and samples to reduce decay dimensions
and then you need something like k over
epsilon to the o of d squared times k to
the 1 over d
time in samples to solve the problem
after you've
done that reduction and setting d
equal to log k this gives us quasi
polynomial
in k over epsilon and recall though that
previously the best known algorithms for
this problem
ran in time exponential in k
so we haven't quite gotten things down
to polynomial
but we have made an exponential
improvement over
what were previously the best algorithms
for this problem
now for parameter estimation um
we things were already pretty good but
we actually still get some improvements
so we still need to assume some sort of
separation
assumptions so let's assume that you
know the mu i
mu j they each differ by about square
root log k
pairwise and that we have this cover
scene now there are some basically known
techniques that allow you to do
parameter estimation given this
in time polynomial in the size of the
cover
basically by using the cover to do
clustering of
points and so the theorem is
given a mixture of k evenly weighted
spherical gaussians
where we've got this separation of
square root log k
there's an algorithm that takes poly m
over k sam
plus k to the d samples this allows us
to compute the first d
moments and then runs in times poly m
over epsilon
plus k to the o of d times k to the one
over d
and learns each of the mu i's to error
epsilon
now what's the point here if we set d
equal to log k
this basically recovers the previous
results that
in quasipolynomial time and samples
learns the means paragraphs
however if you take a smaller value of d
this gives you a trade-off between the
sample complexity and the run time
if we're willing to take you know k to
the 100 samples
then we have run time that's exponential
in k to the 100. um
and so previous works could give you
some sort of qualitatively similar
trade-off
but they could only do it if you assumed
a stronger separation
in order to get this kind of sample uh
complexity runtime tradeoff
previous works require that the means be
separated not just by square root log k
but by
k to the one in d and so
this technique allows us to get the full
trade-off with
only these sort of information
theoretically minimal
separation assumptions
okay so this is what we've attained for
mixtures of spherical gaussians but
if you think about this technique is
actually far more general
for a pretty big sample of light
variable problems you can
follow sort of the same idea you first
learn the parameter moments of the model
by taking samples
you then use this structural result to
go from having parameter moments
to computing a small cover of the set of
parameters
and from there you can run some sort of
algorithm that's exhaustive in the size
of this car
and in particular we have new results
for learning positive linear
combinations values learning mixtures of
linear regressions
and learning mixtures of hyperplanes and
so to quickly look at a couple of those
um so there's this sum of religious
problems so
you have f of x it's a function of the
following form
it's the sum i going from 1 to k a i
times the maximum of 0 and x dot wi this
latter function is a value
and this should be for some non-negative
numbers a i
and w i's of l 2 norm equal to 1.
now what your output is given is it's
given samples x
y where x is say a standard gaussian and
y is equal to f
x plus some independent noise
and the goal is to learn f tilde that is
close to the original f
in say l2 now
what was previously known about this
problem well um
i have a previous paper with ilius and a
couple of his students
that basically says that well we can
compute the first
two parameter moments in this model that
allows us to reduce decay dimensions
and then we can do a brute force search
there and
so we get some runtime that's polynomial
and
m over epsilon but then exponential in k
well that's if you only compute the two
parameter moments but if you're willing
to compute
logarithmically many parameter moments
you can
use an algorithm very similar to the
type we've talked about
and you get a run time and sample
complexity
poly m over epsilon plus something
quasi-polynomial and k over x
the other problem i'd like to talk about
is mixtures of linear regressions
so here what you have is you've got some
beta i's in rm
and some weights that add up to one the
algorithm gets samples
xy where x is a standard gaussian
and well what you do is you randomly
pick one of the betas with this
according to this distribution and then
you set y
is equal to beta i dot x plus some noise
now uh so if you just have a single beta
i this would be a linear regression
problem but because we have you know
a random you know we pick a random beta
i
we have a mixture of different linear
regressions and
there are several goals you might have
but a natural one is to try and just
learn the distribution over pairs x y to
error epsilon
now here there actually is some notable
past work there's a paper by
chen li and song which solves a sort of
similar problem in this vein
in time polynomial and m and exponential
in
square root k and this was is
pretty substantial it still improves
over the earlier works of the run time
is exponential in k rather than its
square root
however once again using these ideas you
compute the parameter moments
of this distribution you use it to get a
cover you then do something exhaustive
you need to pull out some tricks here to
sort of cluster the points and do
something iterative
but you end up with an algorithm for
learning these mixtures
uh with runtime and sample complexity
that's polynomial in m log one over
alpha over epsilon and quasi polynomial
again and k
over and so once again we have sort of
an
exponential improvement over other known
algorithms for this problem
and so in conclusion we've developed a
few things firstly we have this
new structural result we said it says
that if you have a bunch of polynomials
and look at the set
of near zeros of that collection
within some ball that actually has a
relatively small
cover by epsilon balls
this gives rise to a new algorithmic
technique
where if you can compute these parameter
moments you can use the structural
result to find a small cover of the set
of means
and from there you can use exhaustive
techniques that often lead to
quasi-polynomial time algorithms
for a pretty substantial number of
problems
and finally we have specific
applications of this technique
we have the first sub-exponential time
algorithms for
learning density estimation for mixtures
of spherical gaussians
learning positive linear combinations of
values and learning mixtures of linear
regressions
um so yeah that's all i had to say
are there any questions great thanks a
lot
um so i have a quick question
the algebraic geometry result that you
use on the dimension of the variety
is it alexander or shovitz or is it
something more elementary than that
um i guess i don't know the names of the
results it's been a while since i took
an algebraic geometry class
oh okay no problem but okay but this is
tight
this bound that you gave
this variety is tight uh in particular
uh if you just take a a subspace of that
dimension
and then look at all the polynomials
that vanish on the subspace
um i mean the the co-dimension of the
set of polynomials will be exactly d
plus the direction so then my next
question is
so what we expect is in the dimension of
the cover i mean the size of the cover
is to have something
which is exponential in d not d squared
uh yeah you expect it to be only
d rather than d squared and the proof
technique for this proposition
gives d squared and it's
it wouldn't be surprising if there was
an improvement but uh
it took enough work to get what i had
that uh finding this improvement that
you know would
improve your algorithms from you know uh
k to the log squared k to k to the log k
didn't seem worth it right and also
because the dimension is tight it means
you cannot go beyond quasi polynomial
with this technique right
um the technique as it currently stands
is generally not going to be able to
give you better than quasi-polynomial
because yeah
d times k to the one d uh can't do
better than that
um there is maybe some hope
of being i mean
the dimension should continue to shrink
as you as you make things bigger d
times k to the one over d is is not
necessarily a tight bound i mean
really what you should be looking at and
i have to go way back to find this
um was um
or was this bound that k is an upper
bound on d
plus the dimension of the variety choose
d and
this actually should give you something
slightly better than d times k to the
one in d
um on the other hand i mean you
quasi polynomial is still a natural
barrier because
if you have to compute all of the
moments up to degree d
you have this extra factor in your run
time that's already going to
oh right right right right um and so i
have a few ideas on how to get around
that potentially
but uh without some substantial
improvements to this technique
quasi-polynomial is going to be a
barrier that's hard to beat
great thanks a lot um any other question
okay we're already running five minutes
late so maybe less end
here thanks a lot danielle okay sure
and shy if you want to share your